members of the Academy distinguished
guests ladies and gentlemen allow when
you speak about science rather than the
oven heard it's an enormous honor to be
selected as one of this year's Nobel
laureates in chemistry I would like to
thank the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences for bestowing the Nobel Prize
on me along with my co laureates Richard
Henderson
injector Boucher the thought of being
considered a peer of Ernest Rutherford
Marie Curie and Linus Pauling is truly
daunting I developed an interest in
electron microscopy when I worked with
Ernst kinder on oops he developed an
interest in electron microscope when I
worked with Ernst kinder on my master
thesis and physics at the University of
Munich my thesis had something to do
with Beck scattering of electrons in
1943 working with the electron
microscope he had studied butterfly
wings which as he realized gained their
brilliant colors from interference of
light on gratings formed by tiny scales
arranged in a regular order I signed on
II to a graduate project with Walter
hopper at the Max Planck Institute in
Munich an x-ray crystallographer who had
developed an interest in electron
microscopy as a means to study
biomolecules he viewed the electron
microscope as just the diffractometer
that unlike the one employed an x-ray
crystallography could record not just
amplitudes of diffractive electrons but
their phases as well this was just a
fancy way of saying electron microscopes
were able to form images for the
beginning years from 1930s to the 1950s
the contributions of electron microscopy
to biology were confined mainly to the
investigation
tissue serious forays into a
quantitative visualization of molecular
structure did not start until the 1960s
and were concentrated in three groups
Aaron cloak at the lap of molecular
biology the MRC and Cambridge my mentor
Walter hopper at the Max Planck
Institute in Munich and Edward
kallenberger as you heard at the beer
central in Basel now unless symmetries
are present three-dimensional
reconstruction of an object requires the
combination of its projections from a
white angular range first pioneering
achievements in molecular structure in
molecular structure research with the
electron microscope with a
three-dimensional reconstruction of the
barrack of bacteriophage tail with
helical symmetry in 1968 by the ricean
Kruk and the first reconstruction of an
icosahedral virus in 1970 by tony
Crowther in the same lab he at that time
biological molecules could not be imaged
in a close to native state negative
staining which amounts to embedding the
molecule in a layer of heavy metal salt
was the only means available to produce
contrast on the other hand biological
molecules are quite fragile and it was
known that maintenance of the integrity
would require a fully hydrated
environment when I started my work as a
graduate student of under the water
hopper I was exposed to discussions in
small workshops in the turul Alps
co-organized by Walter hopper and Max
Perutz in Alba and once in here check
these were the first meetings that
brought together protein and
crystallographers and people working in
electron microscopy the many problems
faced in attempting to image biological
molecules in the electron microscope
we're discussed at
workshop Inc he organized by edward
carnby n guys in the Swiss Alps in 1973
the state of the art at the time was
reflected in the title of a proceedings
paper since high resolution was equated
with any results better than 30
angstroms paramount at the meeting was
the search for a method that would keep
the molecule fully hydrated while
exports to the electron beam following
pioneering studies by Bob Glazer in 1971
just at the time I visited his lab as a
heartless fellow radiation damage was
recognized as a major obstacle in the
strife toward higher resolution
averaging of a large number of repeats
of a structure exposed to very low dose
was seen as a general solution to this
problem
thus this meeting set the stage for a
groundbreaking study by Richard
Henderson a nodule on wind that you have
already heard about in 1975 the
reconstruction of Barbara carrier Dobson
from the purple Mandarin of hollaback da
embedded in glucose and the quasi native
conditions the confluence of novel
approaches to sample preparation data
collection at extremely low electron
dose and merging a tilt series of these
noisy images made this work a towering
achievement the time after that was
marked by general excitement in the
community and many attempts to use the
same or similar methods in the study of
other proteins amenable to a two
dimensional crystallization however the
intrinsically low contrast between
proteins and glucose made this attempts
difficult and embedment and eyes
remained the agreed general goal at the
time most researchers in the field that
was to be called structural biology were
united in the belief that serious
structure determination required highly
ordered samples such as 2d crystals he
liver fibers or viruses with high
symmetry attempts to extract
structural information from freestanding
single a symmetric molecules were not
taken seriously one such alternative
approach pursued by Walter hopper he was
to tilt the Ingrid - which isolated
molecules were attached in the multiple
angles while collecting projections from
which the molecules could be
reconstructed while the angles are
exactly known in Hoppus tomographic
approached the accumulation of radiation
damage over multiple exposures to more
than a thousand electrons per angstrom
square at the time rendered the end
result essentially meaningless the other
approach was the one I formulated in a
concept paper in 1975 which I will
elaborate in the following so this
approach takes advantage of the fact
that biological molecules purified from
cell extract and suspended in solution
typically exist in thousands or even
millions of copies that is separate
realizations of the same structure hence
if agreed to which such a sample has
been applied it put into the electron
microscope a large number of projection
image of the same molecules lying in
random orientations are encountered the
important point is that instead of
collecting multiple images from one
molecule by tilting it in the electron
microscope one merely has to take a
snapshot of multiple copies of that
molecule with a very small radiation
dose the advantage in the latter case is
of course that the 3d image obtained
relates to a molecule that has seen only
one single low exposure and has remained
practically and damaged the term
determines single particle averaging and
single party reconstruction which were
later coined refer to the fact that the
molecules in the sample are freestanding
and not attached to one another as in a
crystal
so at this point it is important to
reiterate that no symmetries are assumed
in this approach rather the idea was
that entirely a symmetric molecules
could be reconstructed in this way
symmetries obviously simplify the
problem as in that case the image
contains multiple projections of the
repeating unit in different known
orientations allowing data from
different molecules to be readily merged
now simple as the concept sounds the
realization of simple particular
construction required several problems
to be solved all in the area of image
processing first is it feasible at all
to align noisy image molecule images
with one another with sufficient
accuracy second how do we obtain how do
we estimate the resolution of a
reconstruction obtained by combining all
images third how do we sort molecule
images by appearance related to view
angle and confirmation fourth how do we
find the viewing angles of projections
our posterior fifth how do we
reconstruct molecules in a molecule from
projections at randomly spaced new
angles so it was in the nature of these
problems and their novelty that progress
was slow and piecewise one step at a
time
during the work on my PhD thesis which
was 1968 through 1970 had already
explored the use of cross correlation
function for Alanna electron micrographs
I discovered there two successive images
of the same area of carbon could be
aligned with a position of better than 3
angstroms actually the process of 2d
alignment is a bit more complicated
since molecules picked from the
micrograph differ both in shift and
rotation the solution I found to
determine both relative rotation angles
and shift simultaneously makes use of
the fact that the autocorrelation
function
and of a molecule is a shift invariant
it does not depend on its position
within the image frame then working with
Bourne Sexton at the old Cavendish lab
in the group headed by Vernon crosslet I
was able to show that alignment by a
cross correlation would be accurate
enough for the purpose of aligning noisy
images of single molecules if the dose
exceeded a certain level which depended
on the molecule size and contrast
against the background using the
ribosome as an example it became clear
from the formula we obtained that single
particle approach to structural research
was indeed feasible for molecules of
sufficient size my appointment P in 1975
as senior research scientist at the
division of labs and research later
named what's worth Sunday and Albany
offered me the opportunity to explore
the idea with the help of samples
provided by collaborators I was able to
demonstrate the feasibility of obtaining
two-dimensional averages showing
enhanced features of molecules with
images of glutamine synthetase as a real
culinary septa and 40s ribosomal
subunits from HeLa cells among these the
40s subunit averages were most striking
in showing the potential of the single
particle technique and proof
instrumental for gaining funding by the
National Institute of Health nonetheless
presentations of single particle
averaging results at the meeting it were
given in 1975 1709 by myself and my
collaborators Martin Cassell and Peter
Kingston were greeted with a great deal
of skepticism one issue to be addressed
which I had already mentioned before was
the fact that due to the absence of
crystal order the average of aligned
molecule images shows no diffraction
spots in its Fourier transform in the
air for lexan inherent
measure of resolution without such
measure progress and quality cannot be
tracked and compared among different
groups following an earlier study during
my dissertation on the effects of drift
on electron micrograph I realized that
signal bandwidth is reflected by the
extent of reproducible information in
Fourier space this extent of
reproducible information is apparent
from Young's fringes that show up in the
optical diffraction pattern when two is
excessive mica grass of the same
specimen field are superposed with a
slight shift applied how can this idea
be translated into computation
computational procedure reproducibility
can be quantified by dividing the data
randomly in half then comparing the
Fourier transforms of half averages over
rings in Fourier space resolution is
then defined as the ring radius we are a
measure in where a measure of comparison
for instance the phase residual or our
factor or cross correlation passes a
critical threshold the same measures
computed over shells would later prove
important in estimated resolution of 3d
reconstructions as well
these first studies of image averaging
immediately brought up the problem of
heterogeneity only those Molly took
molecule images could be combined in an
average if they originated from
molecules of identical structure and
showed the same view at that time one of
iron stone broken students Marine Fern
Hill visited my lab with images of
Limulus Polyphemus hemocyanin which is
an oligomer with the distinct
architecture producing multiple prefer
to use when negatively stained an image
in the electron microscope these images
therefore presented a perfect example of
heterogeneity the solution to this
problem came from the inside that images
once aligned with one another may be
regarded as vectors in a space of n
dimensions where
n is the number of pixels groups of
images that are similar will show up as
clusters and of vectors in that high
dimensional space equivalent problems of
finding clusters in high dimensional
space were encountered in many fields of
science and gave rise to multivariate
statistical analysis a procedure which
determines a compact low dimensional
subspace tailored to the problem with
the help of jean-pierre Britta da what
was sent a scientist working in
laboratory medicine we were able to use
a program meant to sort blood samples to
sort images instead application to
hemocyanin proved the great success
early on as a set out on this new
approach to recovering structure it
became also clear to me that in order to
make systematic progress in the
development of algorithms and computer
programs with ever-changing in expanding
goals required a workbench with a large
set of tools to this end I developed a
modular image processing system called
spider which made it possible to design
complex programs from pre crowded
building blocks using a simple script
language for example the command W I
would invoke a routine for extracting
Yurchenko portion of an image and a C
would compute the autocorrelation of an
image all programs were coded in Fortran
the most advanced language at the time
most of the initial programming was done
by a student of computer science and one
undergraduate the script language of
spider then became literally the lingua
franca in my lab and as the suit was
disseminated to other labs within a
growing community of users I attribute
the idea underlying a spider system and
it's modern and it's modular design
to my stay at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory in 1970 under the Hartness
the fellowship during this one year
visit I learned the right program
modules that interfaced with Vic are the
image processing system in use by NASA
since 1966 for analyzing images from
planetary missions such as the unmanned
Jupiter flyby mission now to the subject
of three-dimensional reconstruction for
computing the three-dimensional
structure of an object from its
projections one requires the angles of
each projection to be known
determination of the angles of the
randomly oriented molecules was the most
important yet most difficult problem to
be solved the solution came from the
insider to micrographs one of a field of
untilled at particles one of the same
field he tilted contained all the
information required to assign Eulerian
angles to each tilted particle in this
geometry the angles of the tilted
particle projections lie on a cone with
a random azimuth giving rise later to
the term random conical reconstruction
in 1982 I was joined by Michael
Rademacher also the student of Walter
hopper who had worked in his
dissertation on algorithms for 3d
reconstruction from projections arranged
in a regular Chronicle geometry thus he
had exactly the skills needed to have it
develop computer programs that
implemented the random Chronicle
reconstruction one important step was
still missing the generalization of the
algorithm that assumed irregularly
spaced conical tilting to the general
case of random angles once this was
accomplished by Radha Maha in 1986 we
obtained the first single party
reconstruction using the random
Chronicle method the 50s subunit of the
e coli ribosome this reconstruction was
limited in quality by two factors one
was the missing cone of information in
the three dimensional fourier transform
a source of unidirectional artifacts in
the three-dimensional density map and
the other way the artifact stood the
preparation of the sample by air drying
with negative stain both were ethically
overcome at the time within a short
period the missing cone problem was
solved by merging datasets obtained with
three or more different 0 degree views
and the preparation of the sample with
negative staining was replaced by a cry
embedding in vitreous eyes following the
spectacular success of jerk du Burgess
verification method in the application
to viruses in 1984 yet another important
problem affecting the quality of all
records work instructions from e/m data
is the distortion of information by
contrast transfer function or a CDF
caused by the lens aberrations of the
electron microscope this problem and its
effect on the reconstructed density Maps
was eventually overcome by my group and
by others through merging data obtained
with different D focus settings
using a wiener filter algorithm the
first molecules visualized by a cryo-em
and reconstructed in three dimensions
with a single particle method where the
e.coli ribosome hemocyanin and cuts him
release channel a cranium reconstruction
of the hollow ocular Mauresmo TOA
ribosome proved to be helpful in the
facing of the first x-ray structure of
the large subunit all final
reconstructions benefit from an
iterative in angular refinement that
starts out with the first rough
reconstruction in any project dealing
with a molecule whose structures unknown
it is practical to distinguish between
two phases a bootstrap face and a
refinement phase and bootstrap phase a
first rough reconstruction is obtained
either by the random chronicle method or
by an alternative method developed by
Moravian Hill and others in which common
lines in Fourier space are employed in
the refinement Phase II an existing
reconstruction is used to generate the
library of even spaced projections with
which the experimental projections are
compared to assign refined angles to
them for the next round of
reconstruction now I would like to show
a few examples for how the new
technology well before it's reached the
present state of perfection gave us
important insights into pivotal
processes of translation by the ribosome
in the late 90s one of my postdocs
Rajendra organ are well prepared a
sample contain the elongation fact G
bound to the ribosome as it catalyzes
translocation of mRNA and tRNAs
comparison of the cryo-em reconstruction
with that of the unbound ribosome show
the dramatic change
the small subunit head road headed by
almost 10 degrees
this finding provided first clues on the
mechanism of Emma and a tRNA
translocation in this important
molecular machine in 2002 another
postdoc Michael voila I'm sorry in an in
2002 another post of Michael valor found
that in a decoding process tRNA entered
the ribosome in complex with protein
factor ef-tu
in a strongly distorted form in the so
called a T state this observation
indicated that the tRNA acts as a
molecular spring apparently setting the
threshold for discrimination between
cognate and near cognate codon and
decode on pairing as a third example in
2001 we teamed up with Jennifer Doudna
then at Yale to visualize the mRNA from
hepatitis C virus in the process of
hijacking the human ribosome my postdoc
Christian spawn working alongside with
Jeff chief from the Doudna team
visualized the so called iris element of
the virus attacking the small subunit of
the ribosome
even though before 2013 when the camera
the cameras came out in a crime
reconstruction fell short of resolutions
in the 3d angstrom range it was still
possible to interpret them on the basis
of existing structures by means of
flexible fittings such as mdff deriving
interpretations through atomic models
I'm showing two examples among many a
six point I angstrom cry a map
presenting a snapshot of the decoding
process and its interpretation by
Elizabeth Villa
and the atomic model of the ribosome
from t Brucie built from 5.5 angstrom
map by yasser Hashem still from data
recorded on film I finally come to a
distinct advantage of single particle I
am that is brought out in many
applications now here unlike in x-ray
crystallography molecules are
unconstrained by crystal packing and are
able to assume the full range of
confirmations present present in
solution for a process of molecular
machine like the ribosome unless it is
stopped by a chemical intervention many
different states coexist in solution the
full potential of single particle IEM
has been realized for the introduction
of maximum likelihood classification by
co-chairs who worked as a student in the
lab of Jose Maria Caruso and later
independently at the LMB MRC and
Cambridge these algorithms perform the
assumingly impossible task of
disentangling changes of you angles from
changes in structure a large well
characterized ribosome data said that we
as supplied was correctly classified in
the initial study working with his to it
said multiple structures are now
routinely recovered from single sample
in the next slide in the next slide
shown I show two examples several state
of the translation a negation cycle are
fished out from images of ribosome
purified from a cell extract of
Plasmodium falciparum the malaria
parasite the second example on the right
is another study by my group where part
of the elongation cycle is visualized in
an example containing a mutant of a
negation factor G literary cry M is now
able to tell us a story from a single
sample showing how the molecule change
the shape and binds smaller molecules as
it performs its work ultimately even the
recovery of a continuum of structures
reflecting the states of a molecule at
work and the mapping of the free energy
landscape are no longer a distant goal
even though I have illustrated the
progress achieved by using my favorite
molecule the ribosome which now has the
best resolution of 2.5 angstrom the
range of applications in biologists is
virtually unlimited except for some
lower bound on molecule size and of
course the necessity of having the
molecule suspended in solution my own
recent collaborations II where the
groups with the groups of and remarks
Wayne Hendrickson Alexander Sokolov
Sookie and Philippa Marcia demonstrate
the gain and knowledge achievable now
for membrane bound channels and
receptors to conclude this account of 40
year journey I must confess that even
though I was always a firm believer and
the technique I dreamt up many years ago
I never thought it would see it and come
to fruition in this spectacular way let
alone that I would earn that it would
earn me a share of the highest prize
coveted by scientists all over the world
it has been a truly fantastic journey of
all the knowledge that human medicine as
a whole stands to benefit from the new
technology is ultimately the best reward
I would at this point I would I should
at this point you give tribute to old
people who have made this development
possible over the years it goes without
saying that without the pivotal
contributions by my co laureates dr.
Boucher and Richard Henderson the field
would not have developed and prospered
in this way my things go to many
students postdocs and collaborators who
shared my vision had put it put in so
much hard work to make it all happen
what grass uchi has been with my group
for more than 30 years in management and
support of instruments with ever
increasing complexity my very special
thanks goes to my wife Carol Saginaw who
has steadily supported me for close to
40 years and never lost faith in me in
my family and friends who have cheered
me on at every turn
much of the early developments of the
technique took place at the Watts Matt
Santa in Albany which provided a
sheltered supportive environment with
generous funding by the inner state of
New York particularly in the starting
phase in my expression of cattitude to
the Watts words and I would like to
single out Carmen Mandela who supported
me throughout those years as a colleague
collaborator and friend my affiliation
with the department of biomedical
science at the University of Albany
since 85 allowed me to foster academic
interactions with SUNY faculty at large
and since 2008 when I joined the faculty
of Columbia department of biomedical
sciences and biological sciences
I enjoyed multifaceted intellectual
environment foster and maintained by one
of the count country's greatest
universities my workmates been
generously supported by the National
Institute of General Medical Sciences of
NIH almost without interruption since
1981 funding for two inspiring
sabbatical states in England and Germany
was provided respectively by the Fogarty
foundation at the humoured Foundation I
received sizeable awards from the
National Science Foundation for
instrument purchases and support by the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute for
almost 20 years has allowed me to build
up a state-of-the-art professionally
supported cryo-em facility firstly the
Watts Watts Center and later at Columbia
University thank you
[Music]
could I please ask colore its thank you
[Applause]
[Music]